hello everyone
thanks for joining me here after a
series of talks and events
um throughout the day my name is shadi
oshnay
i'm the manager of sound and vision
basically working on
image audio signal video processing here
at pull from research
let's get started i've already put in
chat
i've put two poll questions not to make
it too difficult
if you could kindly take a minute to
give us some feedback
whether you have already got started and
if so
what do you wish to see in the upcoming
features upcoming versions that would be
great
in version 12 1 we
introduced video as a first class
citizen in in the wolfram language
with that in addition to the object and
basically just
a video player came a few limited number
of editing and analysis capabilities
version 12.2 takes that to a different
level
adds a good number of new capabilities
by adding functions to generate video
perform additional basic editing and do
filtering and analysis
this talk is basically a demonstration
of the current state
of video capabilities in the wolfram
language
i will go through the things that had
been released earlier in version
12 one as well just so that this is a
complete status update on
what is in so as i said already in 12.1
we had video
object we had some content extraction
basic editing
and some processing and analysis as well
as programmatic
playback coming in 12-2
video generation more editing more
analysis
and in fact some renames compared to
version 12.1
is coming towards the end of the talk
also or throughout the talk i'll also
mention
what is up next for us as far as
development
of video capabilities
there is a question about what version
is needed to run this notebook
yes a 12.2 version is needed
and a lot of these have been added to
the nightly builds of 12.2 very recently
so depending of which version of 12-2
you have
things may or may not be present all
right
let's get started in a video in the
wolfram language
is all other core um so
when i have a file um like this mp4
sitting somewhere on my
file system i can wrap a video wrapper
around it
and basically get a representation of
the video object
in there if i click on that by default
on
on all platforms the video starts in an
external player
in my case on mac it is quicktime player
there are hardware um other
uh type settings for this video object
like this minimal
user interface or a basic user interface
with some controls to play um
change position change volume and so
forth of the video object
the reason why this is still not the
default and we were hoping 12
2 is going to have one of these views as
the default view of the video object
and is that we require library link
support
which is a technology to send
to communicate data
from um efficient cc plus plus libraries
to um to our system we have that
connection between
mathematical wolfram language kernel um
to c plus plus code we don't yet have
that
for the front end that's on top of the
list that's coming and video
player is going to be one of the first
users of library link
support in the front end so eventually
this is just a prototype of what
a video gui may look like in the future
just a proof of concept
an efficient version of this is going to
be coming
hopefully in the next big release or
release of the
of the wolfram language the fact that
video is out of
core um which means only the amount of
data that has to be displayed gets
fetched at any time
and makes it possible to access video
files that are
hours long in this case i have a video
recording
of one of stephen's physics live streams
and this is almost a two hour video at
screen resolution 25 frames per
again and well i may not be able to play
this
efficiently in a notebook um however
i'll be able to analyze this just like
i'll be able to analyze any other file
that i will show in this demo
okay um support um
for files that have multiple video audio
subtitle tracks
um are as well in um in our mind there
are not that many
video files that have more than one
video and more than one audio track
there are very few that have
any subtitle however there is
applications for this out there
and our design basically goes around the
fact that we
we are aware that this is a possibility
a lot of the containers out there for
video content allow for
multiple tracks and as well our system
is ready to take those in
we do have an extensive support for
codex uh
here are the
formats that be that we support for
encoding
and each one of these containers may
have um
data stored in different video codecs or
audio codecs or subtitle codecs
and there is a large number of those
supported
i i would think it's going to be rare if
um
there is a video that we cannot handle
however a trick is that we
we are using ffmpeg as a back end and
it's
um it's really helping if you install
ffmpeg
on your machine because a lot of these
codecs are patented
um and it's it's not gonna be
possible for anyone to have these out of
the box readily available to everyone
however ffmpeg makes all of those
available to everyone so if you install
ffmpeg
you can basically get access to more
codecs
both for decoding and encoding and then
as well for encoding which is writing to
a file
also there are all common containers or
formats
most common encoders codecs are
supported for export
content extraction a video always
contains
um as i said typically a video track and
some
you know potentially most commonly audio
tracks as well
so here with the video that we showed
earlier we have um one
video track three audio two subtitle
tracks
um and in fact i may be able to just
quickly show
how we think we're gonna be ready to
even
display so if i start playback of this
video object
i'll be able to see or switch
ace crown flight feathers and tail are
black their upper parts are gray
are there are the male adults as well as
showing displaying
uh one of the subtitle tracks
um so with that um we have functions
that can extract frames video frame list
equally or randomly select or pick
some frames out of the um
um video file and then readily available
you have a suite of image processing
then that can put
these frames together or analyze them in
whatever way
there is also video extract frames which
you can give it an explicit time or list
of times
and just extract data from that time of
interest
the audio data stored in the video can
also be extracted by simply wrapping
audio around the video
um this must be a bug in recent
um in in the build i'm using
but assuming this work then the
spectrogram would simply be
a spectrogram of any audio
um just as if i have done something like
um i actually think this other one may
work
in this particular build all right
so that worked
and then with that i'll be able to just
compute something like spectrogram of
audio
and in fact the example i had earlier
was if i have a video um
[Music]
this is a not so nice feature i have a
video
um connected to that mp4 file and if i
extract audio out of it same thing
spectrogram
of audio is going to be the same thing
okay um track selection 12 2
so this was not available in 201
video object has these three
options video track selection audio
track selection and subtitle
track selection so my video comes with
six tracks
one three and two of video audio
subtitles
and i can say whether i'm interested in
having all of them
in my video object and i'm
interested in analyzing or processing
all of those or i would like to simply
just
connect to one or some of those and not
all of them
so looking back at the wolfing wolfinch
video that i showed earlier
this is the video that i showed however
if i construct my video object
with those options saying i just want to
look at the first audio track and i
don't care about subtitle tracks
if i construct that video object and get
information of that
this basically gives me just the tracks
of interest
and the options are also accessible
through import which is something we
already had in 201
however as i had up there in the
notes there was a rename in option names
from
the text
to video track selection and onboard
so make note of that these are all
coming out experimental and we may
change the design
um along the way just to make sure this
is
getting to the correct design
along the same lines we would like to
have a time selection option
and the name we have reserved for it so
far is video time selection
and for instance the same video that i
showed earlier the almost two hour live
stream
um i'm just interested in a minute and a
half of it
and eventually not in 12 2 i'll be able
to say
okay this is my video but i'm only
interested in that
minute and a half of that video and all
of these track selection time selections
are happening
lazily which means there is no
transcoding happening
by setting those options those options
sit there until you
need them and then if you say i want to
say do any analysis on that minute and a
half
we jump to that time and that time
selection specifies and just start
processing or analyzing
starting from there
video generation is something we had
already started from version 201
an example stephen also showed in the
keynote is creating video objects from
manipulates
here for instance i have a simple
manipulate one slider
a lot of those on the demonstrations
website and if i just wrap video
around this manipulate object i'll get
the video version of
this manipulate which is frame wipe by
frame rasterization and
export of what you see
as you scroll through that slider and so
the one above was a manipulate the one
below is a video object
now something that's coming in version
12 2
is generation of video from functions a
function that we are
introducing in this version is called
video generator
if you simply pass to it one image or a
function that creates
images with an argument that is time
this shouldn't really take a long time
so i'll go ahead and just
create it here you get a video object
again
a video file sits on the file system and
we'll talk about where we store things
and then at the default at or specified
frame rate you generate all of those
frames and then
export it to the specified file
use cases of this a lot of times we have
um we have 3d objects whether they're 3d
graphics 3d geometry or anything else
that we would like to move around so
that we see
all sides of it video generator
can simply take these and with any
transformation
in this case i'm defining a simple
rotation transform
can basically take
take this function that goes around or
rotates around the 3d object
as it rotates generates the frame
rasterizes them
puts them into the video file
and right so these are just four frames
of of the file
in the future what we have on the
pipeline
we almost got it for 12 to barely miss
the
release or the freeze we had last week
recording from the webcam
just like we had current image um which
is
giving us one image frame from the
webcam at a time we're going to have
some function that creates a video from
a webcam uh
with some user interface that you're
able to start or stop
and definitely a programmatic way of
doing that um
recording the screen just as i'm
presenting now either my whole screen or
a specific notebook or a s or a specific
bounding box from the screen we will be
able to record
um and and we really think there is a
need
uh for um
having video um sort of consumer
oriented application oriented ways
of uh creating videos from um
for specific needs like as i said
rotating around the 3d object is a very
common thing so
we do envision having more
high level very specific video generator
functions in the system coming up either
from our team
if they are very generic or from other
teams like
the geo team or the graphics team and so
forth
another thing that has been requested a
couple of times manipulate recording
with full control over
controls of the manipulate and that as
well is something that we have
talked about
we have really worked on it um however
that's as well we understand something
that a lot of especially our users
are interested in having the performance
of video generator compared to list
animate
is a question mikey last on chat
there is a huge difference between list
animate and video generator
and when it comes to performance the
problem i see with listanimate is that
if you have so many frames if your list
is very long and every expression
is large it just
simply cannot fit into the notebook and
um
the notebook becomes bigger the slider
becomes
slower to manipulate and so forth and
you
can basically just have it for a
dedicated amount of time
as opposed to video generator with as it
rasterize every frames it writes it to
the file
so you can create hours of animations or
data
as you need you're not limited to
the memory that you have available on
on your machine or anything so it's
really i think the biggest difference is
uh between in-core
and limited encore and i would say a
little more efficient
and all available in the notebook or out
of core but
with no bounds or limitations on the
memory
programmatic playback again
something we had already released in
version 201 once i have a video object
i can also have a video stream handle
connected to that
this video stream has some properties
similar to the video object
things i can do with it i can actually
ask for
let me take this piece out for the time
being
i can ask for things like current frame
or position
let me get this one as well going
dynamically shouldn't pink box ideally
and then i can say video play and as i
video play
the frame is showing up up there
and the position is down here
[Music]
and what i had there let me just
[Music]
pause i think the video was a bit too
loud
um what i have there is exactly
identical to what we
had shown for years as dynamic of
some function of current image so this
is
this is really a stream of frames coming
now from a file
instead of any device and we connect to
that we can process it as we go
and it's it's all um all efficient
let's move on to video analysis we
all believe at least around the team
that analysis is going to be
our biggest strength when we talk about
video in the world from
language the reason for that is that
there is a
vast number of functions for statistical
analysis machine learning
neural networks and then visualization
which
is typically bundled with all of those
when it comes to reporting on any kind
of analysis
so i think in the future versions as
well we are going to be putting
a whole lot more effort on analysis
rather than anything else
one of the functions we have uh released
in version 12.1
was video time series this is now being
renamed to video map time series
to be more consistent with the other
namings that we are picking
um in the language uh again i i
i'm linking to a video um
video map time series of any function
um now compared to what we had in
version 12 one called video time series
can take arguments
linking to image audio or time
and if i run this it grinds through the
data frame by frame
computes basically reads in image data
computes the mean
intensity and and basically goes on
and then we can obviously use any
function
like date list plot to visualize the
result that has come back
as you saw there is a progress indicator
that is being widely used
by other teams as well but since video
analysis and video processing is
by nature and not a very fast operation
we are
exhaustively using it around our
capabilities
as a separate example well i had had it
pre-computed so that you don't have to
wait
uh what i'm doing computing a property
partitions of frames for instance
distance between
uh consecutive two frames at the time
and then plotting this basically shows
when
we have uh frame changes
video intervals is another function that
similarly can take a criteria or a
function here
and basically gives me intervals
for which that given criteria holds true
so here again we're just grinding the
data i think i'm still waiting on that
previous computation to
finish let me check or maybe that's
already finished so this one is going
this should as well have a progress
indicator i don't know why it didn't
show up
and so these are the intervals of
interest
uh which basically comes from that or
very very similar to that first
computation i had done
a new function in 12.2 video map list
is very similar to video map time series
with the difference that video map list
returns a list and doesn't
basically have the limitations of time
series which requires
consistent dimension data when you have
arrays
for instance we couldn't do or we can't
still do video map time series of
dominant colors
but now with video map list we can do
that and as i said here dominant colors
returns lists of different lengths
and lists in the wolfram language are
capable of storing
any uh rank ragged arrays and so forth
and with some computation like that we
can flatten the colors get the tally of
those get the word cloud and so forth
it's basically
enabling more analysis capabilities in
our system
in order to analyze video and audio
track at
the same time these functions that can
be specified in all of these analysis
functions that we are adding to the
system
can take these named slot arguments so i
can do things like
video intervals of some mean image
measurement
times mean audio measurements greater
than something so basically i'm looking
for
intervals that i have content both
in uh image and audio tracks and
that's some kind of interval that comes
back from that
computation
and last in this series i have
image waveform plot and image vector
scope plots
which are two functions that we
basically created
as well for version 12 too the main
use of these are in actual video editing
for color grading and so forth or color
adjustments
and i'm looking at those dynamically
with the stream i created earlier
i'll play this as well and then you see
that
these scopes
are modified as the stream is played
okay video editing we are introducing
video editing capabilities
just to make sure people are able to
perform editing operations
get the piece of or interval of interest
or
do any other operations on those i'll
probably skip through these a little
fast as i don't think i have a whole lot
of time left
video trim as obvious as it is trims
first part last part or a part from the
beginning these
are the obvious syntaxes for a function
like that
video delete basically gets rid of or
deletes those intervals that are
specified
so if you say t1 to t2 it basically
deletes that parts and joins the
before and after video split
um and by the way all of these
illustrations are from
our 12-2 documentation i we believe
these are
very um nice and intuitive and hopefully
make understanding our
functions a lot easier so videos split
with the specification of some times
basically splits the video into multiple
videos this is an example video join the
obvious things you have multiple videos
you can join them video combined
basically a parallel version of video
join
um synchronously you can add an audio to
a video which is really powerful when
you
export manipulates to a video file which
ends up being a no sound
video and then you can combine that with
any audio
and you have it all your lies and then
a function video transcode is
capable of doing multiple things you can
transcode to a different container
you have an mp3 you want an og you can
use video transcode you have a video
that is at 30 frames per second you want
15.
you can do that with video transcode and
some neat thing we are experimenting
with
is that we are looking at some
places like twitter and instagram and
say okay we want a video transcode to
that service
obviously a lot of these services
already transcode as well
but we think it's going to be more
efficient if you transcode and then
upload it
you're going to be saving some good
amount of time
with processing we already had video
frame map
in 12.2 in 1.
[Music]
and what video frame map does every
frame
you get a processed version of that
exported to a new file
or a partition partition of video frames
you process them together
put it in the file using
a video that i can quickly maybe
show it's just a ballet i picked from
pixabay which is
a great place for free video um
i can perform things like color convert
to grayscale the obvious thing
i can perform um any effect
um this is one of my favorites i've used
a lot in
image processing demos which basically
adds
a black line around the edges of the
image
let's quickly show this one
and then as well um we could
okay so my next example we do things
like
um i do i do something called leather
boxing window boxing
where you basically need to
comply to specified uh width and height
but you would like to somehow squeeze
your data into it so i resize to up to
300 in each dimensions and then crop to
300 which is basically padding in this
specific case
and using the multi multi
frame case i'm taking um
every 10 frame and then blending the
first
and last of that which is somehow
showing a blend effect over time
of that same video
video frame map is very similar to sorry
video map is very similar to video frame
map with some very subtle differences
the function can take audio and time
data in video map
and what comes out is or should be
exactly specified in the input in video
frame map we
copy whatever track that is not
[Music]
that is not processed video map you have
to specify
what you would want in the output file
audio track apply very quickly processes
the specified
audio track and you can specify which
audio track using
audio track selection
okay um i think this is important so
let's take a minute on that where are we
putting generated files a lot of you who
have played with this
know that we start putting files because
this is video is all at a core
in 12.2 we are introducing a
an option and a variable generated asset
location
and when i am trimming a file a video
the 10 seconds of the video i can
specify where i want to
put it and the destination or the
location can be a directory or an actual
file name
with a possibility of saying i would
like to overwrite
um the file so
if you're working on a project i think
it would be really neat to be able to
say
you know my dollar generated asset
location is my notebook directory and i
want every asset that
gets created along the lines gets placed
into that directory
and this doesn't only work with video
files
um or video operations this is the list
of functions in 12.2 that accept
the generated asset location option more
of it is going to be coming
in the future releases
as i said um a large number of codecs
and containers are
already supported ffmpeg installation on
your system is going to improve
whatever you have out of the box in the
wolfram language
and and also your operating system which
we leverage as well
um in 1211 we switch some of our
defaults for container and codec
we think this is a much better state
compared to 12.1
play with it give us feedback if it is
not
currently most functions like video trim
preserve container and codec
but again i guess if if this is not
really still suitable for some
applications let us know
um and we're going to look at this
next stop um as i said
an analysis is really on top of our list
and i that
all of us believe that's going to be our
strength so more advanced analysis is
going to be up there
tight integration with neural nets and
machine learning probably the number one
requested feature is
net encoders for video um is going to be
up next
efficient player using library link in
the front-end i already said that
more generation more editing more
everything
is going to be coming as most of the
team is fully focused on
video at this point thanks for your time
i'm sorry i went over time i'll try to
quickly catch up with some questions
however we have the meet up on video
processing tomorrow
i requested an hour this is an hour and
a half great
make sure you're there because we are
really excited to hear
feedback from you suggestions wish list
anything that you think is going to be
worthwhile
uh for us to spend time on and then make
your life easier
using google from language for video
computation we're excited to hear that
quickly one question i see on the chat
um
video trim we'll be able to accept
seconds we do accept
quantity seconds and quantity frames or
quantity basically any time you can say
one minute three seconds
um as a time specification or you can
give it as a frame specification so from
frame 100 to to frame 150
uh will wolfram language be able to
capture streaming
videos um yes
this was one of the things we we're um
working with ip cameras for sure um
streaming videos i think some streaming
services are um basically
uh disabling uh recording capabilities
we're going to be looking
a little more carefully into that but
practically if you're streaming
on your screen and recording that you
could basically do that as well
um i guess with so many other software
so we're going to be supporting that
separate different channels i i think
that's meant to separate different
tracks
we don't have it
however we can specify uh the track of
interest
using the video audio track selection
options and then
export specifically the track of
interest into an
audio or video file so i guess there is
a workaround for that but we don't have
something like
we had for images we had color separate
for audio we had
audio channel separate i think we don't
have a dedicated function for
track separation as of yet
all right if no other questions
um let's hold it here and stephen is
going to
be having another um
i guess event coming up thank you very
much for joining me again